I am so excited to see this and I have
to say on camera I can't believe I'm
talking to you about a Terminator movie
right it's amazing
this is can you talk about the fact that
this is not taking place after the other
sequels this is right after Terminator 2
right well we wanted to keep the
storyline clear obviously with time
travel it can be interrupted at any
point and they just shot off in somebody
in different directions as a matter of
fact I think I died of leukemia but now
I'm not dead so we just kept a trim
what was it about the script how did how
did you get sold on coming back with it
something you wanted to do or was it
sort of like the script kami when you're
like oh this is really good story line
was explained to me
[Music]
so it was a leap of faith because there
wasn't really a script yet and it
a number of weeks
because
back there you know I kept saying I was
retiring to champion after the second
washer to come back and be compared to
myself 27 years before that so it's a
winning proposition yes but in the end
knowing that there was just a world
and I had stopped into this character
and create some money that's just even
that much more authentic
well what I'm just so excited to see Tim
Miller this his first film since
Deadpool I know that he's going to
deliver some incredible action what was
it like working with him to craft the
action to bring this world to life he's
a genius and there there was something
called a brevis where he would have to
actually animate the action sequences
for us to understand well what the hell
he was talking about
so you wouldn't believe how many times I
would be like let me say the brave is
again because these are there and I'm
doing what it was so complex that I mean
I've never read the script and gone oh
like it was so complex where the
characters are who's fighting off who
and what's happening with it but you
know I can't give it away but you're
truly I've never done a film where I
couldn't understand
what he was singing and what he was
trying to invent so we had to rely on
the previz a lot and just basically just
had our heads down there all the time to
make sure that we were all on the same
one of the things Terminator 2 one of my
all-time favorite films the action the
visual effects everything about that
movie pushed the boundary forward for
the cinematic where everyone did does
this film do you feel like this film
does something similar in terms of the
action in terms of the story and for the
Terminator franchise in terms of
narrowly down to characters again that
you really care about as opposed to just
empty the kitchen sink and having so
many different versions of terminators
so many different characters without
really cohesive
story that keeps you interested I think
that we've returned to Mora
and then the action you know it's Tim
Miller it was going to be fantastic so
our job was really I mean obviously to
satisfy him but to also like reinvent
the franchise as a platform for
characters that you care about it's and
simpler storylines
it grabs the attention completely thank
you so much for your well your top